let's talk about Bernie Sanders a little
bit there's a new smear against Bernie
Sanders obviously from the right but
even from some of the anti Bernie crowd
within the left over what Bernie Sanders
said at his recent CNN Town Hall a
couple of days ago that people in prison
should have the right to vote okay now
we have a poll on our YouTube community
page if you go to youtube.com slash the
david pakman show slash community you
can vote on whether you believe that
prisoners should have the right to vote
or not there was an attempt made to sort
of trap Bernie with this ridiculous idea
that if you want prisoners to have the
right to vote that could include people
even like the Boston Marathon bomber for
example and Bernie as he did during the
Fox News debate really did a good job of
avoiding the trap and you're gonna hear
some other people in this first short
clip give their opinions other town hall
participants from CNN you're going to
hear Bernie Sanders give his opinion
you'll hear Camille Harris who has a
total cop-out reaction which is let's
have that conversation she was Attorney
General of California okay she should
have a position on whether people in
prison should be able to vote and she
should just tell us what that position
is let's have a conversation as a total
cop-out and then you'll hear a Peter
Pete Buddha judge say just know he
doesn't think people in prison should
have the right to vote take a look at
this to begin with I think the right to
vote is inherent to our democracy yes
even for terrible people people who are
in convicted in prison like the Boston
Marathon bomber on death row people who
are convicted of sexual assault they
should be able to vote I think we should
have that conversation while
incarcerated yeah no I don't think so
okay so now let's actually get more of
what Bernie Sanders said it in a little
bit more than just one short soundbite
and in fact right here as you may know
in New Hampshire the legislature and the
governor are working hard to make it
more difficult for young people to vote
and to me that is an incredibly
undemocratic
unamerican process and i say to those
people by the way if you don't have the
guts to participate in free and fair
elections you should get another job and
get out of politics all right so we
gotta so here is and to answer your
question as it happens in my own state
of Vermont from the very first days of
our state's history but our Constitution
says is that everybody can vote that is
true so people in jail can vote now here
is my view if somebody commits a serious
crime sexual assault
murder they're going to be punished they
may be in jail for 10 years 20 years 50
years their whole lives so there's a
couple of really good things here that
Bernie Sanders points out there's the
specifics of felons in prison voting and
then there's the general issue of
restricting access to voting to
different groups of people let's start
with the generalities because they're
really important here we have a turnout
problem in the United States of America
half the country doesn't vote but in
addition to that we know that the more
progressive candidate does better the
greater voter turnout is all else being
equal sort of like as a general rule and
as fewer people vote those who do vote
and those who influence voting obtain
secured disproportionately more and more
control over our political system than
others this is actually by design okay
so this is why the right has made it a
focus to try to restrict the voting
rights of all sorts of different people
they want to restrict the voting rights
of the poor by making it harder to vote
on a schedule that's convenient meaning
voting early extended hours weekend
voting whatever that's a specific
political movement with a goal requiring
documents that while the documents in
and of themselves are free they require
other documents which are not always
free to obtain they require taking time
off from work to go stand in line to get
your voter ID that's another way to
limit the number of people voting but
also to sort of target it in a very
particular way limiting where
when you can register to vote or be
asked to vote or limiting automatic
voter registration this is all part of
the same thing it's saying here's a
category of people who we want to have a
more difficult time voting because we do
better we being the right when this
group of people does not vote and it's
really important to be careful about
slippery slopes okay
often there will be claims that if we do
X then Y will happen if two men can get
married all of a sudden a man will be
able to marry a zebra okay that that's a
ridiculous slippery slope animals can't
consent to be parties to contracts among
many other reasons why it's ridiculous
so we don't want to call out a slippery
slope when it doesn't exist but voting
is a right and it should be binary you
have the right period so any restriction
on voting can be used to justify or
normalize further restrictions on voting
and then that gets us to felon
specifically being able to vote while in
prison doesn't shorten your sentence it
doesn't change how bad what you did is
presuming you actually did it and the
justice system worked
prisoners are already so limited in the
ways in which they can influence their
circumstances voting at least makes it
hypothetically possible that they could
have a say on issues like for example
prison reform but more importantly it's
just so binary for me everybody should
have the right to vote and some people
will lay this trap which I've seen of
hey if you let prisoners vote they'll
vote for whoever will give them stuff
like for example saying that they'll let
them out of prison the first reaction is
everybody votes generally speaking for
what they perceive to be in their best
interests that's no different whether
you're in prison or out of prison and
it's not really a reason to say a group
shouldn't be allowed to vote but here's
the more important thing if you believe
that the prison population is so big
that allowing prisoners to vote could
result in electing someone who will
straight up let them out of prison the
reaction shouldn't be they shouldn't be
a
to vote the reaction should be we have
way too many people in prison if the
population is so big that merely
allowing prisoners to vote could change
the results of elections in such a way
that someone promising if you vote for
me I'll let you out of prison could
actually be a playable strategy for
winning an election good for Bernie
Sanders not allowing himself to be
pulled into these irrelevant debates and
what about the Boston bomber voting the
right to vote is binary and I believe
that people in prison should have the
right to vote now I want to hear from
you about what you think you can vote
about this issue at youtube.com slash
the david pakman show slash community
and on tomorrow's show we'll have the
results from our audience in the
meantime let me know your thoughts I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman and the show is
on Twitter at David Pakman show support
those who support the David Pakman show
and today that includes our good friends
over at BR D Bitcoin wallet these guys
are awesome and the BR D Bitcoin wallet
is absolutely perfect for anybody who's
getting into Bitcoin or cryptocurrency
for the first time because it was
designed with simplicity and ease of use
in mind but you'll also love it if you
have experience with Bitcoin it's an
all-in-one app for iOS and Android that
lets you buy Bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies using your credit card
lets you store everything on the app for
free you can trade and sell
cryptocurrency within the app and when
you use BRD wallet you're the only
person who has access to your Bitcoin
BRD doesn't store any of your personal
information you don't even have nor do
you need a username and password on the
platform it's all within an environment
that's virtually impossible to hack so
your cryptocurrency is safe extremely
easy to use
it's how I store my own Bitcoin I think
you'll be impressed with it too it's the
first-ever Bitcoin wallet in the iOS App
Store and now they have over 2 million
users for more than 170 countries BR DS
mission is to make buying selling and
storing Bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies sim
more efficient and more secure and
they've done an awesome job check out my
interview with Aaron from the BRD team
we had a really interesting discussion
about the state of cryptocurrency going
forward you can also download the BRD
app for ios and android i've put a link
right underneath this video